if you go to a google map of rio de
janeiro and put it into 3d mode you can
see what the city looks like as it was
designed by urban planners but you'll
notice parts of the city that don't look
like the rest see the difference the
people who live in these parts of the
city with the clean lines and the
well-thought-out design are called
people of the asphalt the people who
live in these parts of the city are
called people of the hill even though
the people of the asphalt and the people
of the hill live closely intertwined
throughout the city they live vastly
different lives these informal
communities that look like houses
stacked on top of each other are
sprouting out of the jungle are called
favelas home to both vicious drug gangs
as well as some of the most peaceful
creative and resourceful people in Rio I
want to show you what they look like on
the inside
a favela is a community that was built
without any oversight of a public
authority no zoning no building codes no
public services these places just kind
of grew out of the hills over time
thanks to two main factors first was
slavery Brazil imported 11 times more
slaves than the United States did and
real alone was home to more slaves than
the entire American South slavery ended
in 1888 and free slaves still denied
many rights in society built these
informal communities on their own in
more recent times favelas have been
fueled by massive migrations from rural
Brazilians coming into the city looking
for work not able to find affordable
housing these workers built their own
communities today 25% of Rio's residents
live in these favelas I spent time in
six of Rio's favelas to try to figure
out what happens when parts of the city
develop without the presence of a
government
this is Jose Mia its brazil's largest
favela and it has been dubbed a city
within a city it's a completely
self-sufficient economy the result of
decades of makeshift solutions to basic
needs like electricity and running water
without a formal government presence the
residents of ho senior created their own
association which helps coordinate
public projects and resources since
these associations grew up totally
informally by people who had no training
in public administration the resulting
Community Design brings with it a little
more obsessed and creativity than your
traditional city
but make no mistake
Ksenia is a full-on functioning mini
city within the city of rio de janeiro
this impromptu resourcefulness is common
within favelas Here I am in Vidigal a
favela not far from Ksenia this man
Paulo is showing me his garden but it
wasn't always a garden 15 years ago this
hill that we stand on was teeming with
garbage Paulo decided to clean it up
planting trees and cultivating a garden
space that now produces fruit he did
this without asking permission because
after all there was no one to ask
permission from if you look around the
garden you'll realize that everything is
made from trashed
on the other side of the city is a
favela called ma day
people in this community have created
art centers for young people to come and
learn new skills they also support
established artists to create projects
around the city that explore and
communicate life in the favela here they
are building a model of their favela out
of recycled wood in providencia a favela
near the port zone I met up with this
guy
Mauricio a photographer who lives in
this amazing house
Mauricio photographs life in the favela
and provides transparency to the good
and the bad of these places he thinks of
photography as a weapon to fight against
everything from drug cartels to the
government when they show up trying to
remove parts of this community whenever
he sees corruption or foul play in his
community he photographs it and
distributes it to a network of local and
international media contacts over the
years people have learned not to mess
with him a simple begun don't yes a
mahaki dry winter news photography dry
winter nails this has often with fast so
why are these people who live in poverty
and neglect so driven to create beauty
in order to survive it was a simply
spirit el poder who did you put the food
in Catalan prophecy its attention of
society is given be fuzzy fast quizzes
so much baby
see this ultra mega each case either
this reality of neglect from public
investment has created a culture of
creative survival but there's a dark
side to this too
so right now we're traveling over
complexity model which is a huge complex
or block of favelas not going into the
streets today because this place is
still very much run by drug trafficking
gangs I would be sugarcoating the
situation if I didn't talk about the
fact that drug gangs still have major
influence in a lot of the favelas and
Ali Mao is one of those places perhaps
the most powerful gang in Rio is called
the red command a group that began as a
left-wing political rebellion and whose
headquarters are here in Halle Mao
cocaine arrived in Rio in the 1980s
enriching the gangs and allowing them to
grow in power in territory the read
command became more violent and lost its
political ideology focusing entirely on
drug and arms trafficking the favelas
are informal and unregulated it means
both that they can become incredibly
vibrant because people can take this
attitude and build on qualities and be
creative and change your environment but
it also means that you can get
incredibly dysfunctional places when the
energy and the kind of approach is the
opposite so you have these two extremes
and they come out of the same force of
kind of informality and lack of
regulation and kind of flexibility in
2008 the city of Rio was ready to take
over the lawless territories of Rio they
assemble the special force of police
officers to enter the favelas and drive
out the gang influence they called this
process pacification of the favelas but
this gets tricky really fast there's
been this big discussion in the United
States about police brutality but Brazil
is on a whole different level when it
comes to police violence and corruption
Human Rights Watch estimates that US
police kill one person for every thirty
seven thousand arrests in Rio
they say that number is one in every
twenty three arrests so you can see why
some felt skeptical of letting the
police come into the favelas to try to
restore order
this is Santa Martha it's the first
favela that received pacification forces
back in 2008 it also happens to be the
place where Michael Jackson decided to
shoot a music video for their monument
Forge
chagiya chill chill dick method in my I
mean on which plane all profitable
Deepika so but why did the pansy
she was the re pacification worked for
Santa Marta and a few other favelas for
the first few years after 2008 but this
favela is small and the city dedicated
its best police forces to the job it's
been a whole different experience in
places like Ali Mao and other bigger
favelas many of the favelas that I
visited that had apparently been
pacified were very clearly still under
the influence of the red command so
while there have been some successes in
pacification the city still has a huge
challenge ahead of it in taking control
of these places international attention
paid to favelas is usually directed
towards the conflict between the gangs
and the police there's movies and video
games about this this problem has been
perhaps disproportionately amplified
across the world
but while gang violence is certainly a
problem it represents one small slice of
the favela experience what seems to me
as the more striking and interesting
aspect of favelas are the thousands of
men and women who are thriving in
creative ways in spite of being
neglected by their government